[Music]
20-17 is the 40th anniversary of Star
Wars and to celebrate were at the mando
gallery in Austin Texas which is having
a big exhibition of an artist named Mike
Mitchell who did portraits for all of
the great characters in Star Wars this
is Eric Garza he's a creative director
at mono and he's gonna give us a tour so
these are normally impossible for
regular people to get their hands on
they're very exclusive and rare yeah
yeah it's pretty tough to get usually
these were originally available as 72
hour time edition which is a pre-order
so you had three days to jump on and
grab one or however many you'd like
within that window but since then
they've been long sold out we always
knew that South by 2017 we wanted to
have a gallery show so just kind of
culminate in all the collective work
that mike has put into this entire
series and just be able to stand in the
center of a room and look at everything
that he's done over the past year and
over 13 months or so in order to kind of
additionally make that special we've
held back 25 copies of each portrait
that's previously sold out so there's a
bit of a line outside and people are
kind of lining up in the hopes of being
able to pick something up they may have
missed or that they may have not had an
opportunity you get a bit of a line is
kind of an understatement there's like
two blocks of Lion yeah I don't know how
they do it I think the line got started
a couple days ago so and you know all
the power to them we thank them for it I
couldn't do it so I'm glad someone else
kids okay all right so there's a lot
here so show us show us your favor yeah
absolutely so there's we've been doing
this for about 13 months now and and
there's there's a handful of new ones
that are debuting at the show tonight
Darth Vader is one of them's
you notice he has none of the red lenses
which is kind of a throwback to his
appearance and a new hope where if but
the light had it just right you could
kind of see that Vader actually had red
lenses instead of dark lenses it's super
scary it's kind of got like a reptilian
effect and he looks way more
intimidating then you've got obi-wan
just staring daggers oh you have to yeah
you have to have these two paired
together if they're in the show together
then then you have to have them facing
off so obi-wan is actually one of the
ones that word that we're premiering
tonight at the show so he's brand new to
the series so actually don't stop here
because c-3po is probably just my
favorite and in the whole show you know
everything that about the about the way
mike rendered it and the way he drew the
droid is just like perfect he's also
just the best character in Star Wars but
that's that's okay some could say that
that's an opinion you could have so and
then Chu is bigger than everybody
seriously yeah yeah there's a few so so
Mike wanted to kind of have everything
in scale relatively in scale and
proportionate to each other's so yeah
Chewbacca being a larger Wookiee you
know is larger than his bro over there
han Solo but they're looking lovingly
into each other's eyes I have to yeah
read five Luke this is what we kicked
off the series with so he's he's the
original you know February 2016 was when
we first started this Mike Michaud and
Star Wars collaborations so yeah he's
had to put him kind of front and center
in the space yeah so some more debuts Oh
a dangle and the TIE fighter pilot I
don't like knowing that there were
people in the in the TIE fighters right
it just it makes it worse
it's like it's better when it was just
like an inanimate vehicle and I'm humans
they don't have any life Tusken Raiders
is another another one that's that's
premiering tonight at the gallery show
Palpatine as well throw you stopping
here or are you gonna like wallpaper the
walls with the rest of the characters
there's so many more there's so many
more and if you know if Mike wants to
keep doing them then we're gonna keep
doing them so yeah obviously there's
it's an endless well of just like great
imagery and characters so there's still
plenty more to do and
or it's like continuing on
[Music]